- [Narrator] This is
Lucas, the Andean condor.
With wings that spread
up to 10 feet apart,
the Andean condor is one of the
largest flying birds in the world.
Found throughout the Andes Mountains,
the condor is a national symbol
of many South American countries.
The condor has a hairless
head, which changes color,
depending on their emotional state.
In the male, there's a fleshy crest
on the crown of their head,
used to attract females.
It is also one of the
longest living birds,
with some condors living
for more than 70 years.
It is a scavenger bird,
traveling over 100 miles a day
to find carcasses, along
the Andes Mountains,
and sometimes all the way
into the South American coast.
The condor population is in decline,
mostly due to the destruction
of its natural habitat,
as well as lead poisoning from
carcasses shot by hunters.
This is the Andean condor.